[Musique]
tant d'autres femmes vont être sur place
au même moment c'est un pur hasard
est ce qu'on sait si philippe couillard
va rencontrer des dirigeants importants
de haut niveau il rencontrera pas dans
alcon c'est lui le premier ministre
espère rencontrer les politiciens de
haut niveau on peut penser à benyamin
nétanyahou garneau carter est très
proche à la dernière minute on dit à
surprise philippe couillard va jusqu'au
25 mai en israël
qu'est ce qui va faire la recherche et
développement innovation le paradis de
la start up est une équipe qui parle
d'un israël comme une espèce de silicon
valley alors au québec on parle de plus
en plus d'innovation dans le premier
ministre envoie un signal qu'il veut
apprendre d'israël qu'il veut faire des
partenariats avec israël plusieurs
ententes avec les universités alors
qu'un premier ministre se déplace mais
il met tout son poids politique
un martin n'aura pas le temps de se
reposer pendant ce voyage l'itinéraire
jérusalem ramallah a deja wadi ara haifa
et tel aviv
c'est la première fois qu'un premier
ministre québécois qui sera sur la terre
d'israël
on a vu démission de raymond bachand et
de jacques de word 2008 2015
respectivement
qu'est ce qu'on en avait tiré de ses
missions le ce que ça a été vraiment
vraiment concluant on part en voyage en
chine et on a conclu différentes
ententes avec les universités mais aussi
avec quelques entreprises notamment dans
le bio tech dans cette mission aussi ce
sont surtout des jeunes entrepreneurs
qui sont sur internet c'est pas des gens
qui vont vendre des souliers puis des
chandails et des meubles en 2016 les
échanges commerciaux entre le québec
israël se sont élevées à 345 millions de
dollars en hausse de 32% par rapport à
surtout dans le secteur aérospatial
israël c'est le 38e partenaire
commercial du québec